[Music]
in our previous video
we've understood the concept behind
calculating the area
under a simple curve now let's just
apply what we've learned till now
to solve an example based on it
the example asks us to find the area
enclosed by the circle
x square plus y square equal to a square
now x square plus y square equal to a
square
is the equation of a circle with center
at zero comma zero
so with the help of the equation can you
tell me its radius
yes the radius of the given circle will
be a
hence we will mark the points b 0 comma
a and a a comma 0 as shown
the area enclosed by this entire circle
will be equal to
4 times the area of the region aopa
so if we find this area then we can
easily find the entire
area enclosed by the circle now the area
of the region
aoba is the area enclosed by the circle
between the x-axis
and the coordinates x equal to 0 and x
equal to a
now if we consider a vertical strip of
height y
and width dx as shown then the area of
the region
aoba will be equal to the integration 0
to a
y dx thus the area of the entire circle
will be given by 4 times the integration
0 to a
y dx now from the given equation of the
circle
we can write y equal to plus or minus
under root a squared minus
x square since the region aoba
lies in the first quadrant y can be
taken as positive
so on substituting we get the
integration as shown
now the integration of under root a
squared minus
x squared dx looks familiar
can you recall yes it's one of the
useful results that we've derived
using the biparts rule so can you tell
me
what is the integration of under root a
squared minus x squared dx
yes it is 1 by 2 x under root a squared
minus
x square plus a squared by 2 sine
inverse of
x by a plus c hence on applying this
result
and substituting the limits we get the
area enclosed by this circle
as pi a square so that's how you find
the area
under a simple curve we hope that you've
enjoyed this video
[Music]